Scientists want to use sperm to treat tumors
in women’s vaginas!?
That’s right.
Buckle up people.
Gynecological cancers are really hard to treat
. And with over one million women diagnosed
every year, researchers are looking for some
kind of drug delivery method that can survive
in the harsh environments of the vagina, cervix,
and uterus.
It also needs to be able to quickly propel
itself towards a tumor, without diluting the
drug itself.
One group of researchers realized they didn’t
have to look very far to find such a thing
because living, breathing mammals naturally
make something that thrives in that environment…
Sperm.
Sperm are evolutionarily programmed to travel
through the reproductive system and now scientists
are using this to their advantage.
They’re testing bionic bovine sperm to deliver
cancer-treating drugs directly to tumors.
So, how does this method work?
First, researchers take the bovine sperm and
soak them in doxorubicin, which is a type
of chemotherapy drug.
Then, a 3D-printed iron harness is microscopically
fitted onto the sperm.
Sperm themselves are only like .002 inches,
so imagine how tiny that harness would be!
The armored sperm would then be inserted into
the patient's reproductive system.
Once the sperm are inside, the researchers
use magnets to guide the iron-clad sperm to
the drug drop-off point, a tumor.
Then, the bionic suit releases the sperm,
allowing it to swim into the cancerous tumor
and deliver the drug to the problem
area.
At that point, the drug fights to the death,
hoping to overpower and destroy the cancer
cell.
Doxorubicin is a pretty effective drug sometimes
used for cancer treatment.
The struggle has been finding the right delivery
method for the strongest doses, but still
maintaining potency and without damaging nearby
cells. It's not exactly targeted on its own.
And while this drug delivery method may sound
pretty ridiculous (which it kind of is) and
it’s still only effective in the lab, it
could be what scientists, doctors and patients
have all been waiting for.
Now this is obviously a pretty farfetched
use of sperm but scientists are looking into
other ways sperm can help treat various medical
conditions.
Similar methods of sperm-assisted drug delivery
have the potential to treat gynecological
diseases like endometriosis and pelvic inflammatory
disease, but also other diseases throughout
the body.
And scientists are using sperm as inspiration
for nanobots that could help clear clogged
arteries within the body!
More research is definitely needed but it
seems like sperm could be used for a whole
lot more than just makin’ babies.
Microscopic mini machines that can do all
sorts of things in our body is very Honey
I Shrunk The Kids … wanna know more?
We’ve got a whole video on them right here.
What do you guys think of these iron-clad
swimmers?
Let us know in the comments and come back
for more videos!